hello everyone
welcome to another interesting video by
simply learn
in this video
we are going to discuss one of the major
topics that drive the decision making
that is analysis of variance
we will begin this video by discussing
what is anova and what are its types
then we will move on to discuss some key
terminologies to get a clear
understanding of anova
then we'll discuss the concept behind
the working of anova
after that we'll understand the term f
statistics and example to understand how
anova is really used
so let's get started but before we begin
if you love watching tech videos
subscribe to our channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update
so what is analysis of variance
anova is to test the differences among
the means of the population by examining
the amount of variation within each
sample
related to the amount of variation
between the samples
this technique was invented by r a
fischer and is thus often referred to as
the fischer's anova analyzing the
variance test the hypothesis that the
means of two or more populations are
equal
in a regression study analysts use the
anova test to determine the impact of
independent variable onto the dependent
variable
so
what are its types
there are basically two types of anova
which is a one-way anova and a two-way
anova
when we are comparing more than three
groups based on one factor variable
then it is said to be a one-way analysis
of variance
for example
if we want to compare whether or not
mean output of three workers is the same
based on the working hours of the three
workers we'll use a one-way anova
now let's move on to two-way anova
when factor variables are more than two
then it is said to be a two-way analysis
of variance
for example
based on working conditions and working
hours we can compare whether or not the
mean output of three workers is the same
now let's discuss some key terminologies
used in anova
we'll start with null hypothesis
the null hypothesis is the assumption
that an event will not occur
a null hypothesis has no bearing on the
study's outcome unless it is rejected
alternative hypothesis
the alternative hypothesis is a logical
opposite of the null hypothesis
the acceptance of the alternative
hypothesis follows the reduction of the
null hypothesis
h1 is the symbol for it
p-value
in statistics the p-value also called
probability value is a probability
measure of finding the observed or more
extreme results when the null hypothesis
of a given statistical test is true
the p-value is a primary value used to
quantify the statistical significance of
the result of a hypothesis test
now let's move on to alpha value
the alpha value is a criteria for
determining whether test statistics is
statistically significant or not
this test provides a p-value which is
the probability of observing results as
extreme as those in the data
assuming the results are truly due to
chance alone
an alpha value of five percent or lower
is often considered to be statistically
significant
now let's try to understand this
terminologies by taking an example
let's assume that a new drug is
developed with the goal of lowering the
blood pressure more than the existing
drug
so in this case a null hypothesis will
be that the new drug doesn't lower the
blood pressure more than the existing
drug
the alternative hypothesis will be that
a new drug does significantly lower the
blood pressure more than the existing
drug and the p-value will be the result
from evidence like medical trials
showing the positive results which will
reject the null hypothesis
the statistic will be the extent of
difference between the means of
different medical trials
the sum of squares will be the variation
from the mean of different medical
trials
and the mean will be the average of all
the results from evidence like medical
trials
now let's understand the core concept
between how the anova works
the one way anova compares the means
between the groups you are interested in
and determines whether any of those
means are statistically significant
different from each other
specifically test the null hypothesis
if any of the group means is
significantly different from the overall
mean there the null hypothesis in this
case will be rejected
now let's discuss the term f statistics
which is very much used in the
analysis of variance
f statistics or f ratio is a statistical
measure that tells us about the extent
of difference between the means of
different samples
lower the f ratio the closer are the
samples to the means
if you have three different data sets
then this part will be the within group
variance that is
the variance between the
samples this line will be the variance
between the means of the different
samples which is also called between
group variance
if the between group variance is large
relative to the within group variance
the f statistic will be comparatively
large to the critical value and
therefore will be statistically
significant
now that we have covered almost all the
theory regarding the anova let's try to
understand how this is used in a real
world example
suppose you are a marketing manager of
the product company your team has
recently learned three new
advertisements and you want to know if
the three different types of
advertisements affect mean sales
differently
so how can you do that
you will use each type of advertisements
at 20 different stores for one month and
then measure the total sales of each
store for a month
to observe if there's statistically
significant differences in the mean
sales between these three types of
advertisements we'll conduct a one-way
anova
for calculating the anova you will use a
type of advertisement as a factor and
the sales is the response variable
now that we have covered all the topics
in anova and have understood how it is
used in a real-world example
let's see how you can run an anova test
in excel
suppose you are a research scientist and
you want to perform clinical trials to
study the effectiveness of three drugs
developed by three healthcare companies
to cure a certain disease the data below
represents the time taken to cure the
disease for different patients when they
consume either drug a b or c
the time is represented in terms of
total hours and minutes
at the 0.05 level of significance that
is the alpha value we need to test
whether the mean time for the three
drugs to cure the disease are equal so
how we can do that
we'll first move on to the data tab
and then click data analysis
select the anova single factor
and click ok
now it is asking for input range
select the data you have on the table
we have the labels in our first row and
alpha is 0.05
for the output range
we'll get the output here on the same
page so select some cell in the same
page and we'll click ok
so you can see we have our analysis of
variance table
with the summary
let's understand each term one by one
the average time taken to cure the
disease after consumption of three drugs
are 1 0 7
90 and 96 hours approximately
the difference between the largest and
the smallest mean is 17.47
here one significant observation is that
the f value is greater than f critical
value
so
this means we can reject the null
hypothesis
it also means that the average time
taken to cure the disease is not the
same for all the three drugs
using the paired compression we can
conclude that the time taken by the drug
a to cure the disease is more than time
taken by drugsy
and wait further is more time taken by
drug be to cure the disease
that's all about the anova i hope after
this video you will have a clear
understanding of what anoma is and what
is the concept behind it
if you have enjoyed this video don't
forget to click the like button and
subscribe to our channel thank you and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here